so in magnetic confinement
we use another force of nature which is
the electromagnetic force and that's
very it's orders and Orders of magnitude
stronger than the gravitational force
and the key force that matters here is
that if you have a Charged particle that
namely it's a particle that has an
electric net electric charge and it's in
the proximity of a magnetic field then
there is a force which is exerted on
that particle so it's called the lorentz
force for those who are keeping track so
that is the force that we use to replace
physical containment
so in so this again how do you hold
something at 100 million degrees it's
impossible in a physical container this
is not like you know it's not this
plastic bottle holding in this liquid or
a gas chamber what you're doing is
you're using and you're immersing the
fuel in a magnetic field that it
basically exerts a force at a distance
this comes back again to again like why
plazas are so strange it's the same
thing here and if it's immersed in this
magnetic field you're not actually
physically touching it but you're making
a force go onto it so that's the that's
the inherent feature of of magnetic
confinement and then magnetic
confinement devices are like a Toca Mac
are basically uh configurations which
exploit the features of that magnetic
containment there's several features to
it one is that the stronger the strength
of the magnetic field the stronger the
force
and for this reason is that if you
increase the strength of magnetic fields
this means that the containment because
namely the force which you're pushing
against it is more effective
and the other feature is that there is
no Force so for those magnetic fields
what are these things they're also
invisible but you know if you think of a
permanent magnets or your fridge magnet
there are there are field lines which we
actually designate as arrows which are
going around you sometimes see this in
school when you have the you know the
iron filings on a thing and you see the
directions of the magnetic field lines
or or when you use a compass right so
that's telling you nor because we're
living in an immersed magnetic field
made by the Earth which is at very low
intensity magnetic but it's strong
enough we can actually see what
direction is so this is the arrow that
the magnetic field is pointing it's
always pointing North and for us is that
so an interesting feature of this force
is that there is no Force along the
direction of the magnetic field there's
only force in the directions orthogonal
to the magnetic field so this by the way
is a huge deal in in in in in in a whole
other discipline of plasma physics which
is like that the study of like our near
atmosphere so the study of aurora
borealis what's happening in the near
atmosphere what happens when solar
flares hit the magnetic in fact
remember I said Fusion is the reason
that life is responsible
in the universe well you could also
argue so is magnetic confinement because
the the charged particles which are
being emitted from from the Galaxy and
from our own star would be very very
damaging to on Earth so we get two
layers of protection one is the
atmosphere itself but the other one is
the magnetic field which surrounds the
Earth and basically traps these charged
particles so they can't get away it's
the same it's the same it's the same
deal how do you create a strong magnetic
field yeah so with a giant magnet giant
magnet yeah so it isn't basically true
engineering there's essentially there's
essentially two ways to create a magnet
so one of them is that we're familiar
with like fridge magnets and so forth
these are so-called permanent magnets
and what it means is that Within These
the atoms arranged in a particular way
that it produces the electrons basically
a range in a particular way that it
produces a permanent magnetic field that
is set by the material so those 10 those
have a fundamental limitation how strong
they can be and they also tend to have
this like circular shape like this so we
don't use we don't typically use those
so what we use are so-called
electromagnets and what is this it's
like um so the other way to make a
magnetic field also go back to your you
know your your Elementary School physics
uh or science class is that you take a a
nail and you wrap a copper wire around
it and connect it to a battery then it
can pick up iron filings this is an
electromagnet
at its simplest what it is it's an
electric current which is going in a
pattern around and around and around and
what this does is it produces a magnetic
field which goes through it by the laws
of electromagnetism
so that's what an electric that's so
that's how we make the magnetic field in
these in in these configurations and the
key there is that you it's not limited
by the magnetic property of the material
the magnetic field uh amplitude is set
by the amount of the the geometry of
this thing and the amount of electric
current that you're putting through and
the more electric current that you put
through the more magnetic field that you
get the closest one that people maybe
see is one of my one of my favorite
skits actually was Super Dave Osborne on
YouTube it's probably probably past
years again a show called bizarre Super
Dave Osborne which is a great comedian
cult he was a stunt man and one of his
tricks was that he was he gets into a
car and then one of those things in the
junkyard comes down you know and picks
up the car and then puts it into the
into the crusher this is his stunt which
is pretty hilarious anyway
um but that thing that picks him up like
how does that work that's actually not a
permanent magnet it's a it's an
electromagnet and so you can turn by
turning off and on the power supply it
turns off and on the magnetic field so
this means you can pick it up and then
when you switch it off the magnetic
field goes away and the car drops okay
so that's that's what it looks like
speaking of giant magnets MIT and
Commonwealth Fusion systems CFS built a
very large high temperature
superconducting electromagnet that was
ramped up to a field strength of 20
Tesla the most powerful magnetic fields
of its kind ever created down Earth
because I enjoy this kind of thing can
you please tell me about this magnet
yeah sure oh it was it's fun yeah
there's a lot to parse there so maybe uh
we so we already explained an
electromagnet which
in general is what you do is you take
electric current and you force it to to
follow a pattern of some kind typically
like a circular pattern around and
around and around around it goes the
more time the more current and the more
times it goes around the stronger the
magnetic field that you make okay
and as I pointed out it's like really
important in magnetic confinement
because it is the the force that's
produced by that magnet in fact
technically it goes like the magnetic
field squared because it's it's a
pressure which is actually being exerted
on the plasma to keep it contained
uh just just so we know for a magnetic
confinement what is usually the geometry
of the magnet what are we the geometry
yeah so the geometry is typically that
typically is what you do is you want to
produce a magnetic field that Loops back
on itself and the reason for this was
goes down to the nature of the force
that I described
which is that there's no there's no
containment or Force along the direction
of the magnetic field so here's a
magnetic field in fact what what it's
more technically or more graphically
what it's doing is that when the when
the plasma is here's plasma particles
here there's a magnetic field what it
does is it forces all those because of
this this Lorenz force it makes all of
those charged particles execute circular
orbits around the magnetic field and
they go around like this but they stream
freely along the magnetic field line
so this is why the nature of the
containment is that if you can get that
Circle smaller and smaller it stays
further away from Earth temperature
materials that's why the confinement
gets better but the problem is is that
because it free streams along so we just
have a long straight magnetic field okay
it'll just keep leaking out the ends
like really fast so you get rid of the
ends so you basically Loop it back
around so what these look like are
typically donut shaped or more
technically toroidal shape but donut
shaped um things where this collection
of magnetic fields Loops back on itself
and it also for reasons which are more
complicated to explain basically it also
twists it also twists slowly around in
this direction as well too so that's
what it looks like that's what the
plasma looks like because that's what
the fuel looks like so then this means
is that the um the electromagnets are
configured in such a way that it
produces the desired magnetic fields
around this so the precise does this
have to be you were probably listening
to our conversation with some of my
colleagues yesterday so it's actually
it's it depends on the configuration uh
about how you're doing it the
configuration of the plasma the
configuration of the electromagnets and
about how you're achieving this this
requirement
um it it's it's fairly precise but it
doesn't have to be in particularly in
something like a Tokamak what we do is
we produce planar coils that just mean
they're flat and we situate them so if
you think of a circle like this what
does it produce if you put current
through it it produces a magnetic field
which goes through the circle like this
so if you align many of them like this
this this this this there's things
online you can go see the picture to to
you keep arranging these around in a
circle itself this forces the magnetic
field lines to basically just keep
executing around like this so you tend
to align that one tends to re well it
requires good confine or good alignment
it's not like in insane alignment
because you're you're actually
exploiting the symmetry of the situation
to to help it there's another kind of
configuration of magnetic of this kind
of magnetic confinement called a
stellarator which is we have these names
from for historic reasons which is
different than a Taco Mac it's different
than a token that actually works on the
same physical principle that namely in
the end it produces a plasma which Loops
in magnetic fields which loop back on
themselves as well but in that in that
case the totality basically the totality
of the confining magnetic field is
produced by external three-dimensional
magnets so they're Twisted
um and it turns out the Precision of
those is is more stringent yeah so are
taco Mac's by far more popular for
research and development currently than
Stellar Raiders of the concepts which
are there of the token Mac is by far the
most mature in terms of its breadth of
performance and
um and thinking about how it would be
applied in a Fusion Energy System in the
history of this was that many in fact
you asked about if we go back to the
history of the Plato science infusion
center the history of fusion is that
people
scientists had started to work on this
in the 1950s it was all hush-hush and
you know Cold War and all that kind of
stuff and and it's like they realized
holy cow they're like this is like
really hard like we actually don't
really know like what we're doing in
this because everything was at low
temperatures they couldn't get
confinement it was interesting and then
the the they Declassified it and this is
one of the few places that the the west
and the Soviet Union actually
collaborated on was a science even
during the Cold War even during the
middle of the Cold War it was really and
this actually perpetuates all the way
till now for we we can talk about the
the project that that is sort of
captured in now
um
uh but and and the reason they
Declassified it is because like
everything like kind of like sucked
basically you know about trying to make
this confinement and high temperature
plasma and then the Russians then the
Soviets right came along with this
device called the Tokamak which is a
Russian acronym which basically means
magnetic coils arranged in the shape of
a donut and
and um they said holy holy cow like
everyone was stuck at like a meager like
half a million degrees or half a million
degrees which is like in Fusion terms of
zero basically
um and then they come along they say oh
we've actually achieved a temperature 20
times higher than everybody else and
it's actually started to make fusion
reactions and everyone just go oh you
know no way it's just hype from this
it's like there's no way because we
failed at this
um it's a great story in the history of
fusion is that then but this insisters
said no look you can see this from our
data it's like this thing is really hot
and it seems to be working this is you
know late 1960s and there was a uh there
was a team that went from the United
Kingdom's Fusion development lab and
they brought this very fancy amazing new
technology called a laser
and they use this laser and they shot
the laser beam like through the plasma
and by looking at the scattered light
that came from the they go that
basically the scattered light gets more
broadened in its Spectrum if it gets
hotter so you could you could exactly
tell the temperature of this and even
though you're not physically touching
the plasma it's like holy cow you're
right it is like it is 10 million
degrees and so this was one of those
explosions of like everyone in the world
then wanted to build a token back
because it was clearly like wow this is
like so far ahead of everything else
that we tried before
um so that actually has a part of the
the story to MIT in the Plato science
infusion center was why is there a
strong Fusion in a major Fusion program
at MIT it was because we were host to
the Francis bitter magnet laboratory
which is also the National High field
magnet laboratory well you can see where
this goes right from this you know we're
kind of telling the stories backwards
almost but you know the the the Advent
of a Toca Mac along with the fact that
you could makes very strong magnetic
fields with the technology that had been
developed at that laboratory that was
the origins of sort of pushing together
the physics of the of the plasma
containment and the magnet technology
and put them together
in a way that I would say is you know a
very typical MIT success story right we
don't do just just pure science or pure
technology we sort of set up this
intersection between them and there were
several Pioneers that of of my of the of
people at MIT like Bruno copy who's a
professor in the physics department and
Ron Parker who was a professor in
electrical engineering and nuclear
engineering it's like even the makeup of
the people right has got this blends of
Science and Engineering in them and
that's actually was the origin of the
Plato science infusion center was was
doing those things so anyway so back to
this so why so yes tokemax have been
have achieved the highest in magnetic
Fusion by far like the the the best
amounts of these of these conditions
that I had talked about and in fact
pushed raid up to the point where they
were near QP of one they just didn't
quite get over one so can we actually
just Linger on the uh on the
collaboration across different nations
just um yeah maybe looking at the
philosophical aspect of this
even in the Cold War
there's something hopeful to me besides
the energy that these giant
International projects
are
a really powerful way to ease some of
the geopolitical tension even military
conflict across Nations there's a
war in Ukraine
and Russia there's a brewing tension and
conflict with China just the world is
still
um seeking military conflict cold or hot
um what can you say about sort of the
lessons of the 20th century and these
giant projects uh in their ability to
ease some of this tension
so it's it's a great question so as I
said there was a reason because it was
so hard that was one of the reasons they
they Declassified it um and actually
they started working together in some
sense on it as well too and I think it
was really there was
you know and are you ristic or or
altruistic
um aspect to this it's like this is
something that could change you know the
future of humanity and its nature and
its relationship with energy isn't this
something that we should work on
together right and and and that went
along in those ones and in particularly
that any kind of place where you can
actually have an open exchange of of of
people who are sort of at the
intellectual frontiers of your Society
this is a good thing right of being able
to collaborate I've I've had the I mean
I've had have had an amazing you know
career I've worked with people from it's
like hard to throw a dart at a country
and on the map and not hit a country of
people that I've been able to work with
how amazing is that and and even just
getting small numbers of people to
bridge the cultural and societal
societal uh um you know divides is a
very important thing even when it's a
very teeny action of the overall
populations it can be held up as as an
example of that but it's interesting
that if you look at then that continued
collaboration which continues to this
day is that it was it this actually
played a major role in fact in East-West
relations or like so Soviet West
relations Is that
um back in the uh the Reagan Gorbachev
days which of course were interesting in
themselves of all kinds of changes
happening you know on both sides right
um and but still like a desire to you
know push down the stockpile of nuclear
weapons and all that within that context
there was
um a very fairly significant historic
event that at one of the the Reagan
Gorbachev Summits is that they had
really they they didn't get there like
they couldn't figure out how to bargain
to the point of the of the the some some
part of the treaty I can't remember the
details of it anymore
but they needed some kind of a symbol
almost to say but we're still going to
keep working you know towards something
that's important for all of us whether
they pick a fusion project
and that was in the mid-1980s and
actually then after so they basically
signed an agreement that they would move
forward to like literally collaborate on
on a project whose idea would be to show
large net energy gain infusions
commercial viability and work together
on that and very soon after that Japan
joined as did the European Union and now
um that project it evolved over a long
period of time and had some interesting
political ramifications to it but in the
end this actually also had South Korea
India and China join as well too so
you're talking about make major
a major fraction of and now Russian of
course instead of the Soviet Union
um and actually that Coalition is
holding together despite the obvious
political you know uh turmoil that's
going around on all those things and
that's a project called eter which is in
under construction in the south of
France right now